hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime uproar and we finally know the
true identity
the real name and the secret history of
asta's
anti-magic devil in this video
i will be explaining the devil's entire
tragic backstory
and his connection to asta and other
characters in the story
including the devil who is potentially
the strongest
devil of all lucifer i will also break
down what
these new epic revelations about asta's
devil
mean for the story as a whole and what
we can expect from him in the future so
let's get
into it before we get started i want to
thank raid
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
raid shadow legends is the epic
collection rpg game
played by tens of millions of people all
over the world
you can play raid anywhere anytime on
mobile
and desktop there are 10 challenging
dungeons to take down
a thrilling story campaign with 12
different campaign locations
and hundreds of unique champions to
collect
there are 25 million players worldwide
that you can take on
in player to player combat and you can
enjoy unlimited customization
and endless strategic possibilities put
all that together and you get a game
that has basically endless content
and countless ways to play raid is
always getting new
updates and in fact raid just released
the artifact forge
the new advanced quest system with
awesome rewards
and some amazing new champions are
dropping soon
along with the brand new doom tower try
it out for
free just click the link down in the
description and if you act now you get
an exclusive welcome pack that contains
100 000 silver 50 gems 10 mystery shards
and an
epic free champion hex weaver your extra
rewards will be here
in your inbox for the next 30 days only
if you download raid and register
in the game you will be helping out this
channel just click the link
in the description to start playing raid
today
this video will contain black clover
manga spoilers we are talking about the
latest developments
in the story so please proceed with
caution you have been warned
for over 5 years and for over 260
chapters
the single biggest mystery in black
clover has been
osta's anti-magic devil we didn't know
his name
we didn't know where he came from and we
had no idea how he came to possess
the incredibly unique ability known as
anti-magic i spent
so much time wondering about asta's
devil and his true intentions
was he planning on stealing asta's body
or did he want to team up with
osta was he evil like most of the other
devils in the story
or was it actually possible for a devil
to be a good guy
if you've been following my black clover
videos here on the channel
then you know how many times i've talked
about these questions
in the past and now we finally have some
mind-blowing answers we know his real
name
we know his tragic backstory and we know
how he came to reside
inside the five-leaf grimoire we also
know more about anti-magic itself and we
know how the devil came to be connected
to
asta in particular finally we now know
the devil's
true intentions we know what drives him
and what he intends to do with asta
and let me tell you these recent reveals
have been absolutely
epic the devil's real name is liba which
means love
in german he was born inside the
underworld
the dark and mysterious devil world that
appears to be located deep beneath the
earth
kind of like hell is portrayed in
traditional christian literature
like for example in dante's inferno the
world of the devils is
highly elitist and unequal the devils
are divided into different tiers
and these tiers depend entirely on the
levels of mana
that they possess devils like lucifer
stand at the very top
and devils who were born with lower
levels of mana are at the bottom
in fact since the world of the devils is
apparently extremely
boring most devils pass their time by
bullying and abusing those devils who
are below them
on the social ladder liebe was born into
this cruel world
as a devil with absolutely no magic
in this sense he is very similar to osta
who was also born without magic
in a world where almost everyone else
has it the fact that he didn't have any
magic
put liba at the very bottom tier of the
devil society and this led to him being
bullied and abused every single day of
his life
he lived a miserable existence as he was
constantly mocked and attacked by the
other devils
and things became so bad for liba that
he made his peace
with death it was only a matter of time
before the constant abuse at the hands
of the other devils
eventually led to his demise but then
one day as liebe was being mistreated by
the other devils as usual
he was thrown upward at the gate which
separates the devil world from the human
world
presumably this is the same gate that
the tree of cliffhoth is attempting to
open
both liba and his attackers expected his
body to smash
into pieces as it slammed into the gate
but instead liebhe's body simply passed
through the gate and he passed from the
underworld
into the human world this is not
something that anyone was expecting
but apparently it happened because the
gate blocks creatures with magic from
passing through
but it doesn't block creatures without
magic like
liba liba then found himself inside the
human world
on his own normally each devil from the
underworld
fantasizes about finding a human host
which would allow him to enter the human
world
through that host and this is because
the human world is a lot more fun
and interesting than the devil realm but
after everything that he has been
through liba has no desire to attack
humans or to manipulate them in any way
however
because he is a devil and has the
physical appearance of a devil
the humans who come across liba are
immediately scared of him
they just assumed that he must be evil
and dangerous and so they summon the
magic
knights to get rid of him liba is forced
to run from the magic knights and he
eventually collapses somewhere
deep in the woods utterly exhausted from
all the suffering that he has endured
libya accepts that this is the end he
has known
nothing but sorrow in both the devil
world and the human world
and he simply cannot take it any longer
but
then something surprising happens
instead of being killed by the humans
liebe wakes up to find that he has been
taken
in by a human woman named lychita
and this woman has been taking care of
liba and
nursing him back to health this human
woman
is the first creature to ever treat
liebe with
kindness and respect she understands
that he is not a bad guy
just because he is a devil devil or not
he is an injured child
who needs help so lichita decides to
adopt
liba and raise him as her own son
lichita understands liebe better than
most because she
also happens to be an outcast she lives
alone in the middle of nowhere
because her unique absorption magic
makes her someone that the other humans
fear
lychita's body steals magic and life
force from everything around her
including all living creatures she
doesn't seem to be able to turn
this ability off so she is shunned by
society since no one wants their life
force or magic to be drained
by her but because liba is a devil and
because he has no magic
he is able to be around lychita without
suffering any negative consequences
lychita believes that their encounter
was meant to be
and as time passes the two of them form
an incredibly strong bond and they truly
become like mother
and son it is heavily implied that at
some point in the past
lichita was forced to give up her own
biological child to an
orphanage presumably because her magic
made it unsafe for the child
to be around her lichita believes that
meeting liba
was a second chance for her to be a good
mother and although it is not
specifically confirmed yet
it is safe to assume that the child that
lichita was forced to give
up was none other than asta one day
lucifer one of the strongest devils if
not the
strongest devil discovers that liba has
been able to live inside the human world
without the need to find a human host
lucifer is intrigued by this
and he attempts to take over libya's
body by force
he wants to use liba's body in order to
operate within the human world and find
a way to manifest his own
real body into this world as i said
earlier
lichita loves liba and considers him to
be her
own son so when lucifer tries to possess
him
she sacrifices herself in order to save
him
lichita fights back against lucifer and
she manages to force him
out of liba's body by using her unique
magic to absorb
a portion of lucifer's mana because
lucifer
is nowhere near his full power here in
the human world
lichita's plan succeeds but before he
disappears
lucifer manages to pierce lychita's
torso
as he disappears lucifer vows to return
and attack liba again lichita knows that
her time is running out
and that she won't be able to protect
liba next time lucifer comes to get him
so she uses her other ability the
ability to seal anything without magic
inside an inanimate object to seal liba
inside a five-leaf grimoire that she
found at some point
before she had met liba that is how
libra ended up
inside the grimoire the same five-league
grimoire that would eventually choose
osta as its owner lichita then
presumably died from her wounds
but libra was saved as lucifer could not
get to him while he was sealed
inside the grimoire and while sealed
away
liba grew older and stronger but he also
spent all of his time
brooding and seething he just lost
the only person who was ever kind to him
and he was alone
in an empty place all because of lucifer
not only did the devils ruin his life
while he was in the underworld
but they now also ruined his new life
and killed his mother
in the human world liba became obsessed
with the idea of getting revenge on the
devils and destroying
each and every one of them not gonna lie
he's kind of the
eren yeager of black clover a devil who
wants to destroy
all the other devils a titan shifter who
wants to destroy
all the other titans saw his mother die
in front of him
traumatic backstory anger issues it's
all there
while he was inside the grimoire liba's
anti-magic abilities
began to manifest now this might have
been a latent ability that he was always
going to manifest
anyway or it might have been the result
of legita's absorption magic
in my previous black clover video i
speculated that maybe when legita sealed
liba
inside the five-leaf grimoire she
accidentally sealed away
some of her own absorption magic and
maybe even some of lucifer's magic that
she had just absorbed
just before she died perhaps absorption
magic
and lucifer's devil magic along with the
remnants of leaked
sword magic all combined inside the
five-leaf grimoire
and that is what created what we know
today as
anti-magic if lucifer accidentally
contributed to the creation of
anti-magic
then it would explain why it is so
powerful and why it is so effective
against
other devils like zagred since lucifer
is probably the strongest devil
it makes sense that any magic that comes
from him would be very
op and since lychita's magic was to
literally
absorb the magic of others it isn't too
much of a leap to assume that the
ability to negate
the magic of others and use it for
yourself might have been created by
mixing lucifer's magic
and absorption magic and of course we
know that the swords came from leaked
who also had extremely powerful
elf magic i am definitely curious to
find out more about the true nature of
anti-magic
and its mysterious origins in the
meantime though
we have to get back to liba we know that
he's not a bad guy
and both lichita and asta are able to
recognize that
right away but by the time that the
five-leaf grimar finally chooses osta
liba is already obsessed with his hatred
for lucifer and the devils
and getting revenge is the only thing
that drives him
we saw how furious liba became when he
and osta lost to lucifer and dante
and partly as a result of this defeat
liba decided that he must take over
asta's body by
force it's not necessarily that liebe
wants to hurt
asta or to manipulate him but he is so
blinded by hatred and the desire for
revenge that he is prepared to do
whatever it takes to take
out lucifer since liba thinks that asta
is weak due to the fact that he has no
magic
he doesn't trust asta in battle and he
thinks that he will be stronger if he
assumes direct control
over osta i can understand where liba is
coming from
based on everything that he has been
through but it is so ironic that he
underestimates
osta just because he has no magic we
know that liba faced
literally the same stigma since he too
was born without magic
in a world where virtually everyone else
had magic powers
it's almost as if liba is projecting his
own
insecurities on asta and so he is
dismissing asta as weak
because asta reminds him of himself liba
feels that he was too weak to protect
his mother
and he hates himself because of it so
his feelings towards
osta are just a projection of his true
feelings towards himself
or at least that is my professional
opinion as someone who definitely is not
a psychiatrist of any kind
once he is summoned into the physical
world by noct
liba decides to fight asta and force him
to submit to his control
but just like liba himself was always
underestimated by the other devils
osta was underestimated by liba osta
demonstrates that even without magic he
has incredible physical strength
speed stamina and swordsmanship
technique and so
asta is actually able to hold his own
against
liba i just love the relationship
between asta and libas so far
in many ways they are so similar they
both suffered inequality and
discrimination for their entire lives
and in all likelihood they shared the
same mother
at the moment liba's obsession with
revenge is clouding his judgment and he
also doesn't seem to know
that asta was legita's son and that is
why he is trying to take down asta
and possess his body but i believe that
eventually asta and liba will develop a
strong
bond they can both relate to each
other's pain
growing up as outcasts who were mocked
and looked down upon because of their
lack of magic
they both overcame impossible odds in
order to survive
and become impressive warriors if it
turns out that lichita
is indeed asta's mother which seems
highly likely
at this point i bet that liba will come
to understand that helping asta
lichita's first son is a chance for him
to honor his mother
and return the kindness that she had
once shown him
i predict that after liba works out some
of his anger
issues he and asta will come together to
form an
impressive team of adoptive brothers who
are both
fighting for the same goal and i can't
wait to see their brotherly bond
develop let me know what you guys think
are you happy that we finally got
liba's backstory and did you enjoy
learning the secret history
of the anti-magic devil personally i
loved it
and watching asta and liba work out
their brotherly drama
is something that i'm really looking
forward to what do you think is going to
happen next
and how powerful do you think that
anti-magic can become when both liba
and asta learn to work together don't
forget to leave your feedback down in
the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black lover content right
here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed
it's annoying but that's how youtube
works you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you